Rouen Dax Arles Corbeil-Essonnes ou
Versailles les cyberattaques qui visent
les hôpitaux français se multiplient en
2021 l'agence numérique de la santé
l'ANS a répertorié 380 incidents de
sécurité malveillants dans le secteur de
la santé et du médico-social des
cybergressions qui peuvent mettre en
danger la vie des patients alors
pourquoi les hôpitaux sont-ils des
cibles de choix pour les hackers la
réponse dans facture
tout d'abord il faut comprendre comment
les pirates agissent
une des méthodes les plus courantes et
celles de l'attaque au rançongiciel ou
ransonware en anglais voir que la c'est
vraiment l'attaque parfaite l'attaque
informatique parfaite moi je vous
considère que c'est un peu comme la
bombe atomique on s'y perd sécurité
parce qu'une étape une attaqueurs elle
va avoir un impact total cette attaque
se décline en trois étapes la première
consiste à entrer dans le système
informatique la plupart du temps grâce
au hameçonnage ou phishing une méthode
qui consiste à envoyer un email
frauduleux le plus crédible possible
avec un lien ou une pièce jointe
infectée si celle-ci est ouverte elle
ouvre une porte dérobée la bague d'or
c'est la deuxième étape grâce à la
backdoor les pirates peuvent prendre le
contrôle de l'ordinateur puis au fur et
à mesure du réseau il ne reste alors
plus qu'une étape déployée sur le réseau
un rançon logiciel celui-ci va extraire
et chiffrer toutes les données les
rendant utilisable le système
informatique devient alors paralysé en
échange du mot de passe pour
déverrouiller le système les pirates
vont demander une rançon lors de
l'attaque de l'hôpital de
Corbeil-Essonnes elle était de 10
millions de dollars c'était le 21 août
2022 une attaque revendiquée par le
groupe de hacker russe logbit 3.0 mais
les pirates ne sont pas forcés
d'utiliser le fishing ils peuvent
directement exploiter les vulnérabilités
spécifiques aux hôpitaux les hôpitaux
sont des cibles faciles pour les hackers
comme la démontrer l'actualité récente
parce que ce sont des clusters on va
dire à logiciel non mis à jour il y a
énormément énormément d'objets connectés
dans les hôpitaux pas uniquement les
smartphones les tablettes ou les PC du
personnel soignant mais le moindre
appareil que ça soit un IRM un
électrocardiugal tout est connecté et
certains de ces objets sont assez
anciens
face à ces vulnérabilités l'hôpital
manque de moyens évidemment les hôpitaux
ont pas un budget infini en termes
d'informatique si on ajoute
l'obsolescence des systèmes
l'hétérogénéité des équipements qui sont
qui seront connectés dans un réseau
d'hôpital ça roule toutes les parc
informatique très difficile à gérer en
termes de contrôle des gestion des
vulnérabilités qui sont présentes les
hôpitaux n'ont pas suffisamment
infesties dans leur système informatique
face à des contraintes budgétaires
l'hôpital qui est quand même dirigé par
des médecins oriente ses dépenses
beaucoup plus naturellement vers des
équipements médicaux que vers des
dépenses logicielles et là en ce moment
on paye un petit peu le prix de ces
arbitrages qu'on puisse être faits car
il faut sensibiliser et former les
employés effectuer des diagnostics et
des audits pour mettre en oeuvre un plan
de sécurisation cela implique
l'installation de matériel de logiciels
ou encore de services tout un parcours
élaboré par l'ansy l'Agence nationale de
la sécurité des systèmes d'information
et mis en place sur le terrain par des
prestataires en 2021 l'ensis a
accompagné 135 groupements hospitaliers
en France ils ont bénéficié de l'aide du
plan de relance France relance à hauteur
d'une enveloppe de 25 millions d'euros
dédiés à leur cybersécurité en dépit de
cette somme 80 incidents de sécurité
mettant en danger la vie des patients
ont été répertoriés par la ns alors
après la cyberattaque de l'hôpital de
Corbeil-Essonnes le mitre de la Santé a
déclaré augmenté cet investissement la
santé des Français ne doit pas et ne
sera pas prise en otage cette essentiel
c'est totalement inadmissible le jeudi
avec un peu d'émotion dans la voix mais
ce qui vient de se passer ici touchant
des services de réanimation de
réanimation néonatale est inacceptable
nous devons aller encore plus loin nous
allons aller plus loin et nous avons
décidé de renforcer ce plan de 20
millions d'euros justement pour lutter
contre ces attaques de cybersécurité
contre les plus selon François Brown
cette aide devrait doubler le nombre
d'établissements accompagné par la NCIS
outre leur vulnérabilité une autre
raison conduit les pirates à cibler les
hôpitaux l'argent on parle aujourd'hui
de triple extorsion d'abord la demande
de rançon pour déverrouiller le système
ensuite pour ne pas publier les données
volées et enfin l'utilisation des
données en elles-mêmes pour recourir au
chantage les données de santé sont
critiques parce que elles contiennent
tout atteinte d'informations sur les sur
les personnes qui s'agissent des dates
de naissance mais aussi de toutes les
pathologies qu'on peut être enregistrées
et qui sont éventuellement dans un
dossier médical éventuellement des
données bancaires qui peuvent être
attachées des numéros de sécurité
sociale quand même un certain nombre
d'informations que personne n'a envie de
voir sur la place publique les hackers
peuvent faire fuer ces données sur le
Darknet pour inciter les hôpitaux à
payer la rançon mais ils peuvent
également les vendre
selon la firme américaine keeper
security le contenu d'un dossier médical
peut s'échanger entre 100 et 350 dollars
selon les fluctuations du marché en
comparaison les données d'une carte de
crédit volé si revendre aux alentours de
20 dollars seulement car contrairement à
un code de carte bancaire on ne peut pas
changer un dossier médical et surtout il
contient de nombreuses informations
utiles à des fins criminelles ces
données peuvent par exemple servir à une
usurpation d'identité demande
d'allocation faux remboursement à la
sécurité sociale ouverture de compte
bancaire tout cela est possible grâce à
ces données ces données très complètes
pourront aussi être utilisées pendant
des années pour recourir au fishing
c'est ce qu'on appelle la persistance de
la menace il y a un essor de la
cybercriminalité absolument partout avec
des États notamment la Russie qui sont
un peu moins
vigilants sur les les hackers qui
laissent un peu plus proliférer cette
industrie en quelque sorte alors
jusqu'où peut aller la cybermenace
peut-on imaginer en France une attaque
qui plonge une ville dans le noir qui
détraque des feux de signalisation c'est
vrai que le côté hack c'est très
hollywoodien évidemment c'est un
scénario qui fait peur est-ce que c'est
un scénario qui est plausible il n'y a
pas de risque zéro en informatique à
partir du moment quelque chose est
connecté il y a potentiellement un
risque à partir d'un moment il y a un
logiciel il y a potentiellement un
risque maintenant est-ce que c'est
réalisable
dans l'absolu oui est-ce que ça va
arriver on espère que non